for richard branson the time for
preparation is almost up
all the training is about to be tested
for real
and you should probably look out at the
earth
hello down there and if he does make it
to space he says
it'll open the way for others to follow
why shouldn't we
as a human race be able to go in go into
space and and
and uh and marvel at you know marvel at
the world and
and and and have the experience of a
lifetime
and that's only happened to 500 people
roughly
uh since space travel started three two
one release release release if all goes
as smoothly as this last test flight
branson's spaceship
unity will drop from its mothership and
rock it upwards at three times the speed
of sound
50 miles up those aboard will enjoy a
few minutes of weightlessness
a pretty decent view
and for branson victory over his space
rivals
amazon founder jeff bezos won't blast
off for another nine days
although on board with him will be wally
funk denied a trip
when nasa refused to send women now at
82 she'll be the oldest person in space
we land gently on the desert surface
we open the hatch and you step outside
what's the first thing you say
i will say honey that was the best thing
that ever happened to me
[Laughter]
silence of space ticket prices are still
out of this world but those who've been
there
say it is becoming more accessible it's
a little like the evolution of what we
went through with air travel right
you know there was a time where very few
people could have afforded to
to pay the price for an airline ticket i
think it's happening you know i
i i love that all of the
[Music]
the companies doing this too are looking
at it from this way of how
do we give more people this experience
how do we start to
build this up in a way that we can make
it more available
i hope in my lifetime that becomes that
where
i could consider because right now
that's not a price tag i could
and this isn't one of those richard
branson virgin stunts this is about
reassuring those hundreds of people
who've paid
tens of thousands of pounds for a seat
on one of these
that it is safe the message that if he's
happy to go
they should be too it's quite dramatic
yeah so you will get pushed back in your
seat
this is a moment 17 years in the making
for richard branson
with disasters and delays along the way
yeah ridiculously exciting
thank thank you so much it's great we
are though undoubtedly entering
a new era of space travel greg milam sky
news new mexico